excusez moi vous auriez les annales du
bac professionnel vous plaît pour
injection ne penserait au bureautique et
télématique messi quelle section juste
ne cherchez pas bac professionnel vous
n'avez pas base encore c'est tout neuf
cette année il faut avoir le goût de
l'aventuré l'âme d'un pionnier mais pour
ces jeunes ce qui compte plus que tout
c'est d'être arrivé là
au bac olivier ne s'en cache pas il
revient de loin
scolarité difficile orientation par
l'échec vers l'enseignement cours sans
grand espoir d'aller au delà ce bac
professionnel spécialité télématique
représente bien sûr une meilleure
qualification mais aussi et surtout une
chance inespérée voir une revanche je
pense à toutes les années que j'ai
passées à suivre des études que je
m'aperçois que je vais pouvoir enfin
passer mon bac
ça me fait plaisir sachant que eux
avaient des en avait décidé autrement et
que pour eux je vais m'arrêter
donc c'est une certaine revanche
vis-à-vis d'orientation qui m'avait
donné
ce sont les professeurs en fin de
troisième
enfin en fin de collège mon ami décidé
un peu trop rapidement des échanges
ou poursuite d'un élève olivier à 20 ans
deux ans de plus qu'un bachelier
classique mais sa formation et l stages
en entreprise que pour lui se détourner
casa retard on a pris des voies
détournées pour pouvoir passer ce bac
mais à la finale on a l'impression d'en
savoir un peu plus que les autres
bacheliers
on se rapproche plus de ce que demande
l'industrie et eux devront certainement
poursuivre des études pour arriver au
même stade que nous
olivier n'a pas l'intention d'en rester
là à croire qu'il n'en a pas fini de
prendre sa revanche après le bac il
envisage des études supérieures a créé
voilà il était destiné à entrer dans la
vie active voulait pas entrer dans la
vie active
disons que si on reprend les chiffres
qui avaient été fixés 80% des élèves
devaient s'arrêter 20% devaient
continuer alors bon je le place du côté
des 20% quoi vous pensez que avec ce
baccalauréat professionnel
il aura la chance de pouvoir rivaliser
avec les autres bacheliers chanson
persuadé
olivier un cas à part apparemment non
après un passé scolaire jugé difficile
ils semblent tous ou presque avoir
retrouvé le goût des études comme il y
en a parmi vous qui s'imaginent arrêté
après le bac et se mettre à travailler